Melissa McCarthy could be joining the
Disney family also under the sea et has
learned that melissa is in early talks
to star the upcoming live-action Little
Mermaid as the sea witch
Ursula this despite the recent campaign
by rapper Liz o for the park quote I'm
Ursula . so far the film is shrouded in
secrecy no release date announced no
casting announcements no start of
production so day has long been rumored
to play Ariel but she's not spilling any
secrets I don't understand I'm sure
it'll be great when they make it and
I'll go see it like everyone else
did you hear as for Prince Eric back in
2016 Chris Evans said during a panel
discussion Eric would be a dream roll
[Music]
we do know that Rob Marshall director of
Mary Poppins returns will direct
lin-manuel Miranda one of his stars in
Poppins is co-producing and will be
writing some new music to go along with
the classics from the original
[Music]
so it's gonna be so much funny we're
also hearing that Jacob Tremblay is up
for the part of flounder and Aquafina is
in talks for scuttle
[Music]